the pandemic changed a lot about the way
we do business but it also opened up a
world of possibilities working remotely
once just for those in the tech industry
it's really now growing in popularity
for all types of business and co-working
spaces are helping fuel that trend mary
jane belliza joining us live from a new
space that just opened in the southwest
valley to talk about some of the
benefits mary jane good morning
john and heather good morning to you
we're in the upstairs portion of the
coop here on russell and decatur this is
such a beautiful space and even a
beautiful view like i said this is the
big boss office so you can just see how
big it is here i have dana berger and
she is the owner of the coop and you
have two locations which is great i know
you mentioned that you wanted to open it
because you didn't like working from
home but you still wanted a space where
you could have quiet and comfortability
as well exactly yeah so i come from
corporate commercial real estate and
when i left eight years ago i really
missed the camaraderie of an office so
working from home is a nice option once
in a while but then you realize that you
miss that
community you miss the belonging you
miss the water cooler talk and the
connections that you make in an office
space and you mentioned the great part
of having a co-working space too is the
personal relationships that you get to
build with other people because you also
get the comfortability of being alone
and working remotely alone too but also
you get to pop your head in and talk to
other people who share that space with
you exactly so that's the the beauty of
a co-working space is that it's flexible
you can use it how you want so it's nice
to be able to work from home when you
want and it's nice to have a place to go
where you can see some familiar faces
you can meet new people
new business connections people who you
can work with so there's so many
positive things
for example somebody's band is playing
this weekend and
we're all going now you've got something
to do on a saturday night and i know you
mentioned breakfast that was something
you're bringing which is probably
something you don't get in typical
office space either yep exactly so we we
do a feed at the coop each coop location
each month and where we bring breakfast
in from a local catering company one
happens to be one of our members and
it's a time for the members of the
co-working space to come together and
just get to know each other on a more
personal level i love that that is so
cool you don't see that every day in
office space maybe i'd have to drop in
and get some of that breakfast
that's perfect dana thank you so much
and coming up in our next half hour
we'll talk to dr sid karana about the
mental health benefits of being in a
co-working space good morning
yeah john and heather good morning to
you we're in the second location of the
coop on russell and decatur in the
classroom portion of the building this
space is huge perfect enough for
lectures and seminars really a great way
to gather people in your office into one
space i'm here joined early this morning
with dr sid karana with nevada mental
health and thank you so much doctor for
waking up with us so early as we talked
about this is a great way for people who
feel isolated to come together and feel
like they belong correct absolutely that
is true first if i may take a minute
back and say we were forced to do remote
work and with the remote work what you
miss is the sense of embodied presence
just like right now we are here
in the in the zoom screens you just
focus on the face and in the in-person
interactions you can have the non-verbal
cues the whole body language
a sense of presence of the other person
when you don't have that you miss the
organic social interactions
with a place like this a co-working
space
inherently that's what it promotes and
it it increases the sense of
connectivity people feel connected to
each other and when we didn't have that
there was a lot of isolation people
didn't have the drive or the motivation
to leave their home to get to work
and there was a lot of isolation and you
know all about that too because not only
do you meet with patients in person but
even
zoom or remote work as well i do i have
actually been doing telehealth for the
last 14 years i do hybrid work i do
patients i see patients in person and i
see patients who are tele
and and it works but it doesn't work for
all that's right so this is a great way
to have that hybrid connection and also
choose to work remotely as well thank
you so much dr karana reporting live
mary jane balliosa live local now